ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนงวด
นี้ค่ะนักเรียน
ก็เลี่ยมสบายดีไหมคะ
สบายดีค่ะครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋สบายดีไหมคะสบายดี
ค่ะสองคนสบายดีค่ะสบายดีเมื่อวานเดินมากๆ
เหนื่อย
คือทุกวันกูอาจจะนั่งที่นี่นั่งที่
เก้าอี้หน้าอกโห
หลายๆชั่วโมงอาจจะ 5 ชั่วโมง 7 ชั่วโมง 8
ชั่วโมงวันเสาร์จะเป็นวันหยุดที่ปิด
คอมพิวเตอร์แล้วก็ไปข้างนอกแล้วก็ไปเดิน
ก็เลย
เป็นวันเสาร์ก็เลยเหนื่อยเพราะกูเอกก็
เดินเยอะ
ถ้าใช่แต่วันนี้วันวันอะไรและวันอาทิตย์
ข่าวนี้
วันนี้เป็นวันอาทิตย์นะคะให้แลนด์อาทิตย์
ไม่ต้องเดินแต่จริงๆต้องเดินนะเดินวัน
เสาร์แล้วก็เดินวันอาทิตย์เดินติดๆกัน
เหนื่อยจะหายไปแต่พัก 7 วันเดิน 1 ครั้ง
เนี่ยมันก็เลยจะเหนื่อยที่ใน
เขาเรียกว่าปวดขา
ใช่วันนี้วันนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่
คะวันที่ 29 ค่ะวันที่ 29 อ่า
ปิเดือนอะไรคะไม่ใช่เดือนเดือนอ้ายเดือน
พฤษภาคมค่ะกูเองถนัดเขียนนะคะเพราะคลิก
อันนี้กูอาจจะลืมอาปีคศต.ตะไรคะคอสต์
4  22 ค่ะ 2 ขัด 22 ปีพตอะไรคะ
พ.ศ
[เพลง]
2565 ค่ะค่ะแล้วคู่เตรียมนะคะวันนี้สบาย
ดีไหมคะวันนี้สบายดีมากๆดีชาดีมากค่ะสบาย
ดีและตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้
11 โมง
47 นาที
ที่ได้เข็มสั้นอยู่ใกล้ๆเลข 12
เห็นยาวอยู่ที่
เลยเลข 10 มานิดนึง
ใช่ไหม
ป้านะจะเลยขึ้นไปอีกหน่อยนะ
47 นาที
10  11 โมง 40 ก็จะมีไม่เสน่ห์
40  45
อะไรตรงนี้หรือเปล่าไม่ใช่แล้วก็เห็นคุณ
เรียมคนเรียน 15  16  17 ตรงนี้กูอีกแล้ว
งงอ่ะตรงกลางตรงกลางหลังเลย 9 กับเลข 10
คูณเลียม
ประมาณหน้าที่ถูกแล้วถูกครับสุกแล้วถูก
แล้วดีถ้าสุกแล้วค่ะ
ใช่นะคะ 7:00 น 7:00 น 21 นาทีนะคะใช่
แล้วค่ะครูเวลาที่ครูเอ๋จะพูดชื่อครู
เรียมน่ะมีปัญหาตัวเองขอดื่มน้ำก่อนอาร์
นักเรียนดื่มน้ำก่อน
ครูเอกทุเรียนเป็นยังไงคะ
ครูเรียนจะเป็นครูเรียมครูมาเรียมนะคะครู
เรียมวันนี้ครูเอ๋มีเรื่องเล่าให้ฟังคลิป
นี้
ครูเอ๋จะเล่าเรื่องอะไรๆอยากรู้หน้าแบบ
ไม่มีผีไม่มีผี
รุ่นขี่
ไม่มีไม่มีอะไร
มีอะไรไม่รู้เดี๋ยวไปดูกันค่ะนักเรียนนะ
คะอ่ะคลิปนี้ของครูเอ๋ไม่มีผีแต่ยังอยู่
ในความเชื่อของคนไทยนะคะคนไทยเชื่ออะไรคน
ไทยคิดอะไรนะคะกูเอกภัคปลาไปจังหวัดต่างๆ
แล้วก็พานักเรียนไปดูที่คนไทยชื่ออะไร
เดี๋ยวพาโคเรียนไปดูก่อนค่ะเอกเข้าแช่
สกรีนค่ะ
ค่ะครั้งนี้รู้เองที่จังหวัดอะไรคะอ่ะขอ
กู้แต่จะพาไปที่ที่จังหวัดอันนี้เป็น
แผนที่เนาะแผนที่ประเทศไทยน่าจังแผนที่
ประเทศไทยคูเอกทำเล็กๆก่อนนะคะนักเรียน
[เพลง]
โอเค
แผนที่ประเทศไทยผู้เรี่ยมก่อนจะบอกว่า
จังหวัดอะไรประเทศไทยมีกี่จังหวัดคะมี
77 จังหวัดค่ะถ้ามี 77 จังหวัดนะคะนัก
เรียนวันนี้ที่ที่
ครูเอกครูเอ๋จะพาไปเนี่ยลิ้นก็เป็น
จังหวัดนี้ค่ะครูเรียม
ขยายขยายนักเรียนจะได้เห็นชัดๆ
อยู่ค่ะไหนนะคะพี่เอ๋
จังอยู่ภาคกลางภาคกลางเขาบอกภาคกลางแต่
ทำไมกูเองคิดว่าเป็นภาคก็จะออก
ฮะตรางอยู่ตรงนี้ค่ะครูเรียน
นักเรียนสีชมพูน่ะคณะกลืนเป็นภาคกลางแต่
ภาคกลางเนี่ยจริงจะรวมไปถึงตรงนี้ด้วยนะ
เนี่ย
ตรงนี้จะเป็นภาคกลางเนาะ
พักตลาด
อากาศอ่างจะมาถึงตรงนี้ซื้อส่วนตรงนี้จะ
เป็นภาคภาคตะวันออก
ตะวันออกจังหวัดเนี้ยชื่อว่าจังหวัด
ฉะเชิงเทราค่ะครูเรียมจะมิ
ฉะเชิงเทราที่ฉะเชิงเทราเนี่ยเขาจะมีวัด
อยู่วัดนึงนะคะมีจะมีวัด
คูณมองเห็นนะคะมองเห็นค่ะฮู๋มีเล็กที่สระ
[เพลง]
จะมีวัดทุกๆจังหวัดมีวัดนะคะใช่ค่ะใช่ค่ะ
แปลว่าทุกๆจังหวัดมีวัดแต่ฉะเชิงเทราจะมี
วัดอยู่ 1 วัดที่มีชื่อเสียงมีชื่อเสียง
ก็คือมีคนเนี่ยรู้จักมากๆนะคะ
อ่าอย่าใครดีที่มีชื่อถ้าเป็นคนใช่ไหมคะ
คนที่มีที่เสียงอย่างเช่นนักร้อง
/  Michael  Jackson อ้าทุกคนรู้จัก
เพราะว่ามีชื่อเสียงใช่ไหมคะ
รู้เรียม
มีชื่อเสียงหน่อย
ผู้เรียนผู้ AV มีเสียงไหมอันนิดหน่อยนิด
หน่อย
นิดหน่อยมีคนรู้จักนิดหน่อยนะคะแต่ถ้า
ไมเคิลแจ็กสันมีคนรู้จักมากๆเช่นรักร้อง
หรือว่าดาราชนะดาราเช่นแองเจอรีน่าเจอรี่
ก็มีคนรู้จักมากๆเราบอกว่ามีชื่อเสียงแต่
ถ้าเป็นสถานที่อย่างเช่นฝรั่งเศสมีหอ
ไอเฟลใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะเพราะ
มีชื่อเสียงไหมคะขอไอเฟลมีชื่อเสียงค่ะ
โชคมีคนรู้จักเยอะๆใช่หรือว่าถ้า
ญี่ปุ่นก็มีอะไรนะภูเขาไฟภูเขาไปภูเขาไฟ
ฟูจิใช่ไหมมีชื่อเสียง
ที่มีชื่อเสียง
มีคนรู้จัก
อเมริกามีอะไรออกผู้หญิง
มีเทพีเสรีภาพ
อ๋อถือถือๆนะครูเอกชอบคิดถือ I  Scream
by นักเกินมีชื่อเสียงใช่ไหมคะใครที่นี้
ที่ฉะเชิงเทราก็มีวัดนะคะมีวัดที่มีชื่อ
เสียงอยู่ 1 วัดค่ะครูเรียมเดี๋ยวกูเองมี
รูปให้ดูนี่ชื่อวัดอะไรคะคู๋
คนไทยเรียกว่าวัดหลวงพ่อโสธร
สวยมากเหนื่อยไหมใหญ่มากแล้วก็ติดอะไรคะ
คุณเรียมอยู่ติดแม่น้ำ
ฮ่าๆๆปิดแม่น้ำนะคะวัดหลวงพ่อโสธรเนี่ยมี
ชื่อเสียงมากนะคูเรียมเคยได้ยินชื่อไหมคะ
เคยได้ยินค่ะเราก็เคยไปที่วัด 1 ครั้ง
คูเรียมไปด้วยหรอไปทำอะไร a ไปเที่ยวบีไป
ไว้ค้าซีไปดื่มกาแฟ
ดีไปขอไปขออะไรสักอย่างนึง
เอ็มไปเอเอไปเที่ยว
ไปดูใช่ไหมคะเพราะว่าวัดมีชื่อเสียงนะคะ
อ้าวัดหลวงพ่อโสธรเนี่ยมีชื่อเสียงมากโดย
เฉพาะคนที่อยู่ในภาคกลางนะคะคนภาคตะวัน
ออก
คนอาจคน
หมอเขาคนชลบุรีคนระยองเเถวนี้ค่ะจะมาที่
วัดนี้มากๆไปไหว้
ครูเอกเคยไป 2 ครั้งแต่ที่บ้านครูเอ๋แล้ว
พี่สาวครูเอ๋สามีพ่อพ่อแม่พี่ชายทุกคนชอบ
วัดหลวงพ่อโสธร
รักเดี๋ยวกูเอกจะพาไปดูก่อนนะอ่ะทำไมชอบ
ไว้ที่ไหนทำไมถึงชอบห้ามด้านนะคะดีอะได้
คู่เรียมดูก่อนเวลาที่เข้าไปในข้างในนะ
ค่ะข้างในนะคะข้างในก็จะมีหลวงพ่อองค์นี้
ล่ะค่ะองค์หน้าเนี่ยค่ะเขาเรียกว่าหลวง
พ่อโสธรขอโทษนะคะ
นะคะหลวงพ่อโสธร
ซึ่งครูเรียมรู้ไหมว่าองค์จริงน่ะอ้ะถ้า
เราไม่รู้องค์ไหน
นี่องค์ที่ลิงองค์ที่ 1 เลย
ใช่คือองค์จริงคือเขาเขามีองค์จริงแต่เขา
ก็จะมีมีอะไรอยู่ข้างในแล้วก็มีหล่อ
ทับทับๆจนปัจจุบันนี้ไม่มีใครรู้ว่าหลวง
พ่อโสธรองค์จริงน่ะองค์เล็กองค์ใหญ่องค์
ขนาดไหนนะคะบางคนก็บอกว่าเป็นเป็นเป็นไม้
และเป็นไม้องค์จริงบางคนนะกูเอกก็ไม่ทราบ
นะคะกูเอกก็ฟังมานะครับฟังมาอีกทีหนึ่ง
บางคนก็บอกว่าองค์จริงเป็นทองแบบนี้
หนูไม่สูงไม่ใหญ่องค์เล็กๆนะคะแล้วก็ทำ
องค์ใหญ่ๆแล้วองค์เล็กๆอยู่ข้างในเพราะ
ว่าผู้เรียนเห็นไหมคะว่าองค์เนี้ยเที่ยว
และสูงใหญ่จะไม่ได้นะๆมายแล้วก็เลยบอกอาจ
จะทำองค์เล็กๆอยู่ข้างในแล้วก็องค์องค์
อ่ะอ่ะอ่ะข้างนอกเนี่ยทำอาจจะเล่นอะไรนะ
สร้างขึ้นมาเลยหล่อขึ้นมาน่ะหล่อพระให้
ส่งอ่านเลยว่าฉัน
คงเล็กก็ทำเป็นชั้นเป็นชั้นแล้วก็เลยกลาย
เป็นองค์ใหญ่ณตอนนี้ใช่องค์เล็กจะอยู่
ข้างในองค์จริงอยู่ข้างในคือ
ก็ทุกวันนี้ก็ไม่รู้ว่าองค์จริงไม่เคย
เห็นนะคะไม่เคยเห็นจีใครรู้เพราะว่า
ใช่เพราะว่า
นานหลายปีแล้วเนาะมีแต่ว่าถ้าเราไปที่วัด
หลวงพ่อโสธรอ่ะสิ่งหนึ่งที่ครูเอกจะเห็น
และตัวเองก็อะไรล่ะถึงไม่เคยเรียงอะไร
อยู่เหมือนกันคงเรียนผิด
อะไรมีไข่และมีขายเยอะมากหรือว่าวิใครไข่
เป็นอะไรนะแล้วก็มีไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่แบบนี้
หนึ่งล้านนะนะคะผู้เรียนมีเป็นสิบสิบล้าน
ใช่ไหมให้เกิดถ้าขับรถครับคุณจะเห็นร้าน
ขายไข่ต้มไข่ต้มเยอะมากตอนจะเป็นมุก
จะเป็นตะกร้าเดี๋ยวเขาขายเป็นตะกร้าเป็น
จะมีปัญหานอาหารที่คนฉะเชิงเทราชอบกิน
หรือเปล่าคะตัวเอง
กูเรียมถ้าคนชอบกินแต่ใครจะซื้อไข่ต้ม
ทิ้งอันนี้โอเคอันนี้ 89 บาทเล็กๆ
ถ้าร้อยยี่สิบบาทไซส์นี้อันนี้ร้อยห้าสิบ
บาทก็มีไข่เยอะมากเราก็จะมีมีขนาดเนี่ย
180  200  8 ถ้าครูเรียมจะกินไข่ต้มอ่ะ
ครูเตรียมจะซื้อไข่ทิ้ง 20 รูปก็จะมีอะไร
9 ลูก
19 ไม่รู้กิดมากที่สุดก็คือ 99
99 ลูก
กูเรียนจะซื้อไข่ 99 ลูกกลับบ้านกินไหมคะ
ถ้าเกิดถ้าเกิดแบบอยู่ในบ้านเตรียมมีพ่อ
แม่พี่สาวตัวเองอยู่บ้านข้างๆในก็โอเคนะ
ก็ซื้อได้แต่ถ้ากินคนเดียวน่ะกินกินไม่
หมด
ไม่ใช่
แต่ว่าไอ้นกไข่จะซื้อไข่ทีละ 99 ลูกเยอะๆ
ใช่ไหมค่ะเอกทำไมมีขายไข่แล้วแบบเยอะมาก
นะแล้วไข่ต้มแล้วก็รู้สึกว่าเฮ้ยคนแถวนี้
กินไข่ต้มหรอตอนแรกนะงงงง
แต่พอเข้าไปในวัดแล้วถ้าเจอแบบนี้ค่ะนี่
เฮ้ย
กว่าเดิม
กอดคิดคิดว่าอันนี้เท่าไหร่อ่ะกูเยอะมาก
อันนี้เก้าสิบเก้าลูก
Min  1  2  3  4  5  5  6  7  8  9  10
ถ้าคูณสิบน่าจะ
999 ลูกนะ
900 ต้มกัน 999 ลูก
หูคงเยอะกินเยอะขนาด
แล้วก็เห็นอะไรด้วยคะพี่เอ๋ที่อยู่แบบผัด
ไปจากไข่ต้มอ่อดอกไม้ดอกไม้ดอกไม้
มากเลยนะคะร้านดอกไม้นะคะแม็กซ์เรียน
เราก็เริ่มสงสัยว่าอะไรเนี่ยมีไข่ต้มมี
ดอกไม้แล้วที่วัดนี้ทุกๆทำไมมีไข่ต้มเยอะ
แล้วมีอีกอันนึงให้ดูค่ะ
รำละคร
รำละครอันนี้เรียกว่าละครชาตรีราคาชื่อ
ละครชาตรีนะคะก็รำละครก็จะเห็นแบบนี้ค่ะ
นักเรียนอยู่ในบริเวณวัดราคาที่วัดหลวง
พ่อโสธร
ตัวเอกหักแล้วเขาทำไมต้องมีไข่ต้มเยอะๆ
นี่ดอกไม้เยอะๆแล้วก็มีรำละครชาตรี
ที่วัดนี้ค่ะอื่นน่ะไม่มีนะ
ไม่มีล่ะกูเอกก็ไม่รู้นะ
คืออย่างนี้คุณเรียมเหรียญหลวงพ่อโสธร
เนี่ยค่ะเขามีประวัติเขามีความเชื่อเขามี
ความเชื่อว่าถ้าเราอยากได้อะไรผสมว่าครู
เรียมอยากได้อะไรแต่ครูเรียมต้องรู้นะว่า
ครูเรียมอยากได้อะไรนะกูเรียมอยากได้อะไร
ครูเรียมก็ไปที่วัดหรือที่จริงๆที่ไหนก็
ได้นะเพราะว่าที่บ้านครูเอกก็ทำที่บ้านก็
จะจุดธูปนะคะจุดเอ่อคู่เอกพี่
เอไม่แน่ใจว่าจุดกี่ดอกนะคะเดี๋ยวกูอีก
คิดก่อนนะเขาก็บอกว่าจุดธูปหาจุดธูปอ่ะ
3 ดอกไม้ถวายพระท่าไหว้พระน่าจะ 3 ดอกนะ
คะ
แต่ว่าอันนี้เนี่ย
เขาบอกว่าถ้าจุดนะคะจุดทูธ
ถ้าจำไม่ได้จริงๆลืมนักเรียนขอโทษนะฮะไม่
มีไปที่วัดถามได้เพราะคุยไม่เคยทำกูเอกก็
เลยลืมเขาก็จะมีคือถ้าเกิดว่าคุณเรียน
อยู่ที่บ้านกูเรียนจุดธูปได้ถ้าคิดไม่ออก
ว่ากี่ดอกก็เป็นพระก็ 3 ดอก
รัก 3 ดอกได้ก็เอ่อแล้วก็ขอหลวงพ่อโสธร
ช่วยด้วย
แตะๆแต่ไม่ขอลอตเตอรี่รางวัลที่ 1 นะคะ
สมมติขึ้นมา
ทุกคนขอค่ะทุกคนขอ
ทุกคนขอลอตเตอรี่รางวัลที่ 1 นะคะ
ทุกคนขอลอตเตอรี่รางวัลที่ 1 ดังนั้นอัน
นี้นี้ขอท่านก็คงไม่ให้นะคะ
กันเนี้ยก็ขอแล้วถ้าได้อ่ะสมมุติว่าครู
เรียมอะไรดีล่ะกูเริ่มอยากได้มีสมมติถ้า
อยากได้รถ
ยังไงรถใหม่
แต่ตอนนี้นะเงินยังไม่พอใช่เงินไม่มีโอเค
ก็ต้องทำงานเพิ่มแต่งงานยังไม่มี
เงินเดือนไม่ได้เพิ่มใช่ทุเรียนก็จุดธูป
แล้วก็ไปข้างนอกอันนี้ที่บ้านกูอีกชื่อ
อะนะไปปักไว้นอกบ้านสมุดบ้านเดี๋ยวตอนนี้
ต้นไม้
นี้มีพระอาทิตย์
อันนี้เป็นความเชื่อที่บ้านครูอีกน่ะค่ะ
ต้องบอกก่อนอ่ะก็จุดทูแล้วก็
อ่ะผู้เรียนต้องคิดว่าเอ๊ยบ้านครูเรียม
อยู่อยู่อยู่ตรงไหนตรงนี้
บ้านคู่เรียนอยู่มหาสารคามใช่ไหมคะอ่ะคะ
ใช่ค่ะผู้เรียนต้องขันลากมัดไทยต้องหัน
หน้าหันหน้าไปทางวัดหลวงพ่อโสธร
ใช่เกาะใช่ค่ะก็คือท้ายนี้ทิศเหนือ
อันนี้อีสาน
จะได้คะอ่าแต่กูเรียนอยู่อีสานแล้วนะคุณ
เรียนก็ต้องหันหน้ามาผัดก็ไม่คิดถึงที่มี
หลวงพ่อโสธร 1 ผู้เรียนผู้เรียนจะไปทิศ
นี้ก็ไม่ได้เนาะจุดนี้ไม่
เกจะอยู่ออกมาทางใต้ของครูเรียมใช่ไหมคะ
จากทางนีเราก็
แล้วก็ตัดธูปได้ที่แล้วก็ปัดถูกอะขอหัน
หน้าไปแล้วก็ขอ
โง่สะทอนช่วยเรียมด้วยเรียมอยากจะซื้อรถ
ใหม่
แต่เรียงอ่ะยังไม่มีเงิน
ซื้อขายรถเก่าให้ได้
ถ้ามีคนซื้อรถเก่าครูเรียงก็ซื้อรถใหม่
ได้แล้วก็หรือไม่ก็ขอให้เรียนมีงานงานมา
เยอะๆจะได้ซื้อรถใหม่ได้เดี๋ยวเนี้ย
ใช่แล้วนะเรียงก็ขอแล้วถ้าเรียมได้
ได้ทำยังไงคะพูดเอ๋เรียนก็ว่ายระยะไกล
แล้วนะหลายกิโลแล้วนะจ๊ะไหว้จากมหาสารคาม
ถึงฉะเชิงเทราคนนั้น
เตรียมก็ต้องคิดว่าเรียมจะเอาอะไรไปไหว้
หลวงพ่อโสธร
เขาก็บอกว่าให้บนด้วยไข่
ไอ้โต้งฮ่าๆๆบอกว่าถ้าเหลี่ยมได้รถใหม่
เตรียมจะเอาไข่ต้มไปแล้วก็ว่าถ้าแกบ่น
ดีคนไทยขอถ้าได้ก็จะให้อะไรอันเนี้ยเรียก
ว่าบนนะครับบนงั้นเนี่ยถ้ากูเรียนบอกว่า
ถ้าเรียมได้รถใหม่เตรียมจะเอาไข่ต้มกี่
ฟองดีเก้าฟอง
กำฟ้าแห้ง next ค่าอะไรใหญ่ๆเขาก็จะให้
ไข่ตรงเยอะๆค่ะอ๋อ
เราเป็นไข่อย่างอื่นไม่ได้หรอคะหรือว่า
เป็นอย่างอื่นได้ไหมให้กูเองเออส่วนใหญ่
ก็จะไข่ต้มพวงมาลัยดอกไม้หลอกว่าหลวงพ่อ
โสธรรอบไข่เขาบอกว่าเขาบอกว่ากูเอไม่ทราบ
นะคะเขาบอกว่าที่นี่ต้องบนด้วยไข่
อันจริงๆก็คือบริเวณนั้นน่ะค่ะครูเรียม
หมู่บ้านเขาเลี้ยงไก่ไข่เยอะ
กูเรียนอยากบนด้วยอะไรก็ได้ก็คือใครดอก
ไม้ผ้าหรือว่า
ลาคอนนะคะละครแต่ถ้าครูเรียมบนด้วยไข่น่ะ
เพราะว่าให้เสร็จกูเรียนมาเอาขายไปแจกแจก
คนที่ไม่มีเงินกินข้าวได้พอดีๆคิดว่าจะ
ต้องเอาไข่กลับมาที่บ้านมันนั่งกินกิ๊บๆ
ไม่ต้องผู้เรียนก็แจกได้มีคนมาเอาไปแจก
ได้
ต้องถามเขาว่าเอาไข่ไหมคะแล้วก็แจกแค่
ต้องกินกัน
แต่ไม่ต้องเอาไปให้ทำอาหารน่ะ
เอกเคยบนแล้วก็เอาไข่ไปให้หลวงพ่อโสธรไหม
ค่ะอ่ะไม่เคยบ่นค่ะครูเอ๋ไม่เคยบนแต่คู่ a
เคยได้ยิน
รู้จักคนเดียวนะคะคุยลบอันนี้ก่อน
คุยนะรู้จักคนแล้วเขาก็
มีมีรู้จักคน
แอบถ้าเขาเป็นสามีภรรยา
ก็ผิวขาวภรรยาก็ผิวเขาขาวๆและเขาแต่งงาน
นานแล้วแล้วก็ไม่มีลูกก็เลยบนหลวงพ่อโสธร
แล้วเขาก็ได้ลูกลูกสาว
ได้ลูกสาวแต่ลูกสาวผิวสีแทน
จริงๆเข้าเชื่อเขาเชื่อว่ารูปที่ได้จาก
หลวงพ่อโสธรจะผิวสีแทนเขาเล่าให้ครูฟัง
แต่บางทีตรงเนี้ยคุณปู่คุณย่าเนี่ยอ่ะก็
อาจจะมีผิวสีแทนนะคะ
[เพลง]
และอาจจะมี 1 คนคุณปู่คุณย่าคุณตาคุณยาย
น่ะอาจจะมีหนึ่งคนที่ผิวสีแทนแต่ว่าลูก
เค้าเนี่ยลูกเขาได้หลังจากนั้นเขาได้คน
ที่ 1 น่ะเขาบนขอหลวงพ่อโสธรแต่คนที่ 2
ไม่ได้ขอคนที่ 3 ไม่ได้ขอสองคนเนี้ยผิวสี
ขาวนะคะ
ผิวสีขาวก็เขาก็เล่าให้ฟังว่าเนี่ยลูกสาว
เขาเนี่ยอ่ะขอจากหลวงพ่อโสธร 4 เนี่ยไม่
ได้
พูดไม่ดีจนเขาร้องไห้นะไม่ได้เขาเคยตีลูก
เขาแล้วพูดไม่ดีธุรกิจเขาเนี่ย
ไม่โอเคใช่ไหมคะ
เขาก็เลยไปที่วัดก็มี 1 หลอดครับขอแล้ว
ต้องพูดดีๆอ่ะอาร์มพูดไม่กี่นะคะห้ามตี
แล้วเค้าดูเอก
จริงไม่จริงไม่รู้ตอนพี่สาวกูแสร้งงานเรา
ไม่มีลูกนะฮะแล้วก็ไม่สบายเพราะว่าอ่ะยัง
ไม่อยากมีลูกก็เลยกินยาห้ามไม่ให้มีลูก
แล้วไม่สบายน่ะคุณหมอบอกว่าถ้าท้องแล้วจะ
แข็งแรงก็คู่เอกกับคุณแม่มั้งคุณแม่เนี่ย
แหละคุณแม่คู่เอกก็ขอหลวงพ่อโสธร
ก็พี่สาวครูเอกก็เหมือนกันได้ลูกสาว
ผิวสีอะไรคะแล้วก็ผู้หญิงนะคะ
แล้วก็มีลูกชายลูกชายเหมือนกันเลยคนนี้ก็
ผิวสีแทน 2 คนสีขาวคุณพ่อผิวสีขาวแม่สี
ขาวรูปที่ขอหลวงพ่อโสธรสีแพน x จริงหรอ
แต่ว่า
ครูเอกก็คิดหน้า
อันนี้ปู่ย่าเขาก็ผิวสีขาว
พ่อแม่ของครูเอ๋ผิวสีขาวนะแต่ว่าทำงานโดน
สีแทนแต่คุณเนี่ยคุณทวดคนเนี้ยผิวสีแทน
คู่เอกก็คิดแบบสมัยใหม่ก็เอ้ยจริงไม่จริง
ไม่รู้นะคะแต่จริงๆกูเอกก็เคยมี
ประสบการณ์ถ้าพูดไม่ดีแล้วหลานสาวร้องไห้
น่ะคุยกับองค์มี 4 โชคไม่ดี
เพราะว่าเป็นเป็นเป็นอ่าโอเคคุณยายนะคุณ
ยายเนี่ย
ขอจากหลวงพ่อโสธรให้พี่สาวท้องแต่เวลาขอ
ต้องตั้งใจจริงๆนะอ่าคุณยายน่ะก็บอกเอ๋
บอกว่าอ้อลูกหลวงพ่อโสธรให้คนไทยที่อยาก
จะมีลูกก็จะขอจากหลวงพ่อโสธร
ท้องแล้วยายคุณนะคะเราก็ไปขอลูกใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็มีหลายคนที่ไปขออย่างอื่น
ใช่แต่เวลากูขอคุณต้องตั้งใจจริงๆนะต้อง
ตั้งใจแล้วก็เชื่อจริงๆนะคะอาตาว่าก็ต้อง
แต่งงานด้วยนะคะถ้าไม่แต่งงานแล้วขอลูกก็
ไม่ได้นะ
[เพลง]
ไม่ได้
ทรายนัดละบางคนก็ขอไม่ได้คือครูเอกก็ไม่
รู้แต่เขาบอกต้องตั้งใจจริงตัวอย่างบ้าน
ครูเอ๋นะจะนับถือหลวงพ่อโสธรคุณแมนนับถือ
มากนะคะพี่สาวด้วยก็นับถือมากนะน้องหลาน
ชายน่ะคนเนี้ยสองคนเนี้ยก็นับถือมากๆนะฮะ
รู๋ก็นับถือแต่ไม่ใช่แบบไม่ไม่เท่ากับพ่อ
แม่ที่แบบมามากที่สุด
คนที่เขานับถือมากๆเขาก็จะได้ที่ที่เขาขอ
เวลาได้ปั๊บเขาก็จะไปแก้บนนี่
เอาไข่ต้ม
ชาใช่ไข่ต้มแล้วก็ไปแก้บทให้ค่ะ
ก็เป็นเป็นความเชื่อ
เป็นความเชื่อของเขาว่านี่ล่ะค่ะหลวงพ่อ
โสธรเนี่ย
ศักดิ์สิทธิ์ภาษาไทยหรือว่าศักดิ์สิทธิ์
ขอแล้วได้
ก็ได้ประปาจะไปแก้บนแล้วก็เอาเงินน่ะไปทำ
บุญเพื่อที่สร้างวัดให้ใหญ่ขึ้นใหญ่ขึ้น
ใหญ่ขึ้นคู่เรียนรู้ไหมว่าวัดนี้นะ
บางวันน่ะตอนไม่มีโควิชอ่ะมีคนไปไหว้เป็น
หลักหมื่นคนนะคะหนู
[เพลง]
อย่างมา
สวัสดิ์ผู้ใหญ่มากนะๆและรถทำไม
ศักดิ์สิทธิ์แล้วทำไมคนเชื่อเขาก็มี
ประวัตินะคะว่าพระพุทธรูปองค์เนี้ยค่ะ
หรือองค์นี้กูเอกก็ไม่รู้ลอยน้ำมานี่
ลอยน้ำมาจากที่ S
ใช่แต่ว่าลอยน้ำมายังไงคุณเรียมรู้สึกว่า
เวลาเราจะหมดใช่ไหมใช่รถวันนี้เตรียมจะ
รู้ถ้าถามว่าพระลอยน้ำมาได้ยังไงนั่นน่ะ
สิอยากจะรู้ทำไมหลวงพ่อทำไมหลวงพ่อโสธรคน
ไทยจริงเชื่อว่าศักดิ์สิทธิ์มีประวัติยัง
ไงโอนักเรียนหรอกคลิปหน้านะคะ
ใช่วันนี้งานหมดแล้วหมดหมดใช่ไหมหมดจริงๆ
เนอะ
เลี้ยงก็จะรอนักเรียนนี่แหละกำลังรอฟัง
อยู่ค่ะ
หล่อว่าทำไมคนไทยถึงเชื่อว่าศักดิ์สิทธิ์
นะคะนักเรียนคุยกูเองต้องปิดนะคะ
ช้าไม่ถึงศักดิ์สิทธิ์ทำไมคนไทยไปขอแล้ว
ได้จริงไหมคือได้จริงไม่จริงนักเรียนดู
ที่วัดค่ะจากวัดเล็กๆใหญ่ขึ้นใหญ่ขึ้น
ใหญ่ขึ้นใหญ่ขึ้นนะคะอันเนี้ยคือกูเอกก็
ไม่รู้แล้วแต่คนเชื่อแต่ก็เล่าให้ฟังว่า
มีคนไปขอบ้านถ้าจะไปก็ให้ธุรกิจดีบางคน
คือต้องต้องเป็นคนดีด้วยนะที่จะไปขออ้านะ
คะ
อยากรู้ว่าทำไมศักดิ์สิทธิ์วัดหลวงพ่อ
โสธรมาจากไหนเป็นยังไงรอคลิปหน้านะคะนัก
เรียน
ขอโทษนะคู่เรียมไม่ทันขึ้นชั่วโมงไม่ทัน
โอเคค่ะร้อยฟังกันทริปหน้านะคะวันนี้ต้อง
ลาครูเอ๋และนักเรียนไปก่อนแล้วค่ะค่า
สวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบาย
บายน